>> ALL RIGHT.
THE GREAT MAIL-IN BALLOT
CONUNDRUM.
MORE THAN 400,000 HAVE BEEN
FILED AND IT WAS ONLY 75,000
FOUR YEARS AGO.
SO OVERWHELMING, WE’RE GETTING
NEWS OUT OF OHIO, THE PRESIDENT
RETWEETED NEARLY 50,000 VOTERS
RECEIVED THE WRONG BALLOTS IN
OHIO.
AGAIN, RAISING QUESTIONS AS TO
HOW SAFE THE PROCESS IS, HOW
RELIABLE IT IS.
GOVERNOR MIKE DEWINE OF OHIO
WITH US RIGHT NOW.
GOVERNOR, GOOD TO HAVE YOU.
>> GOOD TO BE BACK, THANK YOU.
>> GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
HOPE YOU’RE DOING WELL.
ON THIS 50,000 BALLOT THING,
WHAT HAPPENED?
DO YOU KNOW?
>> NOW, THIS IS FRANKLIN
COUNTY.
I THINK THEY SAID THEY HADD A
VENDOR WHO MADE A MISTAKE AND
TO MAKE SURE THE WAY AT LEAST I
UNDERSTAND IT, YOU HAD SOME
PEOPLE IN A PART OF FRANKLIN
COUNTY THAT GOT THE WRONG LOCAL
NAMES AND IN STATE LEGISLATIVE
RACES.
THAT WOULD NOT HAVE--
THEY OBVIOUSLY, OF COURSE, HAD
THE PRESIDENT ON THERE AND THEY
HAD JOE BIDEN ON THERE.
IT WOULDN’T HAVE IMPACTED THE,
YOU KNOW, THE PRESIDENTIAL, BUT
SOMEBODY CAUGHT IT RIGHT AWAY.
A FORMER STATE LEGISLATOR
ACTUALLY CAUGHT IT AND THEY’RE
CORRECTING IT.
LOOK, MISTAKES CAN HAPPEN.
WE DOESN’T LIKE IT, NO ONE
LIKES TO SEE IT, BUT WE’VE GOT
A RED-HOT RACACE IN OHIO.
I THINK THE PRESIDENT’S GOING
TO WIN IN OHIO, BUT OHIO IS, AS
YOU KNOW, A SWING STATE.
AND IT’S GOING TO GO RIGHT DOWN
TO THE WIRE.
IT’S--
YOU KNOW, WE HAVE VERY
EXPANSIVE VOTING IN OHIO.
PEOPLE CAN GO IN AND VOTE AT
THE BOARD OF ELECTIONS AND ANY
OF THE 88 COUNTIES WHERE THEY
LIVE.
THEY CAN GO INTO THAT LOCAL
BOARD OF ELECTIONS, UP, YOU
KNOW, FOUR WEEKS GOING INTO THE
ELECTION.
AND THEY CAN DO, YOU KNOW, THE
ABSENTEE BALLOT OR CERTAINLY
CAN WAIT UNTIL ELECTION DAY,
WHICH IS WHAT FRAN AND I
USUALLY DO, AND GO IN.
WE HAVE 13 HOURS TO VOTE.
>> YOU KNOW, WE TALK ABOUT HOW
MAIL-IN BALLOTS HAVE BECOME SO
OVERWHELMINGLY POPULAR RIGHT
NOW, AND THEN WE’RE AT FOUR AND
A HALF MILLION NOW, AND THEY
MIGHT BE MORE THAN THAT NOW,
GOVERNOR, BUT IT’S RUNNING AT A
PACE THAT THWARTS THE 75,000 OR
SO THAT WE HAD FOUR YEARS AGO
AT THIS TIME.
THE PRESIDENT’S ARGUMENT HAS
BEEN THAT THAT’S OVERWHELMING
AND RIPE FOR ABUSE.
I KNOW YOU’RE TRYING TO ASSURE
FOLKS THAT IN OHIO THAT WON’T
BE THE CASE.
THIS WAS AN ISSUE MAYBE IN
FRANKLIN COUNTY AND HOPEFULLY
ISOLATED TO AT.
IT’S BEETED, BUTYO
O
APL
INCREASINGLY C TONHAT
TH
D K OTUFFF JUST KEEPS
HA
NG.
>> YEAH, I THINK IFNYBODY IS
CONCERNED, THEY CAN GO IN AND
VOTE.
THEY CAN GO IN AND VOTE ANY DAY
OF THE WEEK, BASICALLY.
MONDAY THROUGH FRIDAY, I
BELIEVE, INITIALLY AND THEN
LATER ON, IT GOES INTO THE
WEEKEND.
SO YOU CAN GO TO YOUR BOARD OF
ELECTIONS MONDAY AND YOU CAN GO
VOTE IF YOU WANT TO DO THAT AND
WE SAW TUESDAY IS THE FIRST DAY
THAT YOU COULD VOTE.
WE SAW LINES UP OUTSIDE OF
BOARDS OF ELECTIONS, SO PEOPLE
HAVE THE OPTION TO DO THAT.
IF THEY DON’T’T WANT TO DEAL WIT
PEOPLE AT ALL.
THEY CAN DO IT ABSENTEE OR THEY
CAN WAIT, YOU KNOW, AND DO IT
ON ELECTION DAY.
WHICH IS WHERE EVERYONE USED TO
DO IT.
IN OHIO, IT LOOKS LIKE WE’RE--
WE’VE DOUBLED THE NUMBER OF
THESE ABSENTEE BALLOTS THAN
WHAT WE HAD FOUR YEARS AGO AT
THIS TIME.
THAT’S WHAT THE SECRETARY OF
STATE’S OFFICE SAYS.
>> YOU KNOW, GOVERNOR, YOU HAD
A SCARE A WHILE BACK WHERE YOU
HAD BRIEFLY TESTED POSITIVE FOR
THE CORONAVIRUS.
TURNS OUT THAT IT MAY HAVE BEEN
A FALSE POSITIVE, AND I HOPE
THAT’S THE CASE AND YOU’RE
HEALTHY AND WELL.
>> IT IS.
BUT--
I’M VERY HAPPY TO HEAR THAT,
GOVERNOR.
YOU KNOW THE DUST-UP OVER THE
PRESIDENT’S CONCERN, AND
WORRIED THAT A LITTLE MORE THAN
A WEEK AFTER BEING IN THE
HOSPITAL AT WALTER REED AND
CLOSE TO TWO WEEKS SINCE HIS
DIAGNOSIS, NOW IS NOT THE TIME
TO BE HAVING CAMPAIGN EVENTS
AND EVEN PROPERLY DISTANCED FOR
THE BALCONY AT THE WHITE HOUSE.
MONDAY IN FLORIDA AND RESUMING
HIS ACTIVITIES.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF ALL THAT?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, I THINK
CAMPAIGN NEEDS TO CONTINUE.
THE PRESIDENT NEEDS TO BE ABLE
TO GET HIS MESSAGE OUT TO THE
PEOPLE OF THE COUNTRY, AND THE
PEOPLE OF THE KEY STATES.
MY POSITION HAS NOT CHANGED.
YOU KNOW.
LARGE GATHERINGS ARE NOT SAFE
WHEN PEOPLE DON’T SOCIAL
DISTANCE AND WHEN THEY DON’T
WEAR MASKS.
SO, YOU KNOW, WE WOULD SAY THE
SAME THING ABOUT ANY POLITICAL
CAMPAIGN.
WE SAID THE SAME THING ABOUT
DEMONSTRATORS EARLIER ON.
WE’VE JUST ASKED PEOPLE, YOU
KNOW, WEAR MASKS, KEEP THE
SOCIAL DISTANCE.
I BELIEVE, NEIL, THAT WE CAN
REALLY DO TWO THINGS AT ONCE,
THAT WE CAN LIVE OUR LIVES AT
THE SAME TIME BE CAUTIOUS AND
PRUDENT ABOUT WHAT WE DO IN
REGARD TO TRY TO KEEP THE
SPREAD DOWN.
AND SO, YOU KNOW, MY IDEAS OR
MY POSITION HAS NOT CHANGED.
IT’S BASED ON THE SCIENCE.
KEEP DISTANCE, BUT WE CAN’T
JUST, YOU KNOW, COWER IN OUR
BEDROOMS AND NOT GO OUT.
WE’VE OPENED -- WE HAVE SCHOOL
OPEN IN OHIO.
AND PEOPLE ARE MAKING THEIR
DECISIONS WHETHER THE SCHOOL IS
REMOTE OR OPEN FIVE DAYS A WAKE
AND MADE BY THE LOCAL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS.
OUR RESTAURANTS ARE OPEN, OUR
BARS AND THEY HAVE SOME
LIMITATIONS ON THE HOURS, BUT
EVERYTHING ELSE IS OPEN.
WE ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO GO ABOUT
YOUR LIVES AND ENCOURAGE THEM
TO BE CAREFUL AND THAT WOULD BE
THE SAME THING WITH THE
POLITICAL RALLY.
>> WELL PUT.
GOVERNOR, GOOD SEEING YOU, GOOD
HEALTH.
BUS OF LUCK TO YOU.
GOVERNOR DEWINE, THE BEAUTIFUL
STATE OF OHIO, A BATTLE GROUND
TO PUT IT MILDLY, JOE BIDEN AND